no sign of the disgraced chris pincher
and his tamworth constituency
represented by tory prime minister sir
robert peale in the 19th century
but now the present prime minister boris
johnson is being accused of ignoring
warnings about mr pincher's sexual
misconduct when he appointed him deputy
chief whip in february
a move that prompted a glowing
endorsement of the pm he won the massive
majority in 2019 he's got all the big
calls right and he'll continue
to do so
mr pincher resigned last thursday after
being accused of groping two men while
drunk at the elite carlton club
but he didn't lose the tory whip until
nearly 24 hours later amid several new
allegations against mr pincher it's
claimed the prime minister turned a
blind eye to warnings about his behavior
that he was worn not once but twice and
that in a meeting with aids in 2020 he
even said pincher by name pinscher by
nature
claims that prompted uncomfortable
questions for cabinet ministers was the
prime minister aware of allegations
around chris pinch's behavior when he
was made deputy chief whip in february
i'm not involved in any of those direct
conversations i'm not aware that he was
made aware of like specific claims about
uh any particular incidents or anything
like that no i'm not i don't believe he
was aware that's what i've been told
today
this is not the first time mr pincher
has resigned as a government whip
in a roller coaster few years he quit as
a whip in november 2017.
in january 2018 he was appointed by
theresa may as deputy chief whip
he served in various ministerial roles
in the government and then in february
this year he was made deputy chief whip
by boris johnson in a cabinet reshuffle
while mr pincher admits drinking far too
much at the carlton club and seeking
medical support
labor claims the pm is guilty of
protecting his allies if you have a
situation no matter what else is going
on where people believe no matter what
they do they will not be held
accountable to that because of their
relationship to boris johnson or the
position or the internal politics of the
conservative party i think you are
asking for the kind of problems which
they have got mr pincher won his seat
from labour in the 2010 general election
when david cameron became prime minister
a cabinet minister under mr cameron says
unless mr pincher quits more tory mps
will question mr johnson's leadership
either chris pincher as we get bottom of
these allegations will have to take
responsibility and decide what he does
but if that is not done then yes it will
reflect on the wider conservative party
particularly in parliament
led by boris johnson and that's why i
think for a lot of the parliamentary
party this comes back to
boris johnson's leadership
in tamworth however voters are critical
of the government and have some sympathy
for their mp
he's got blood i don't know
and he's been he's going a bit over the
top but for 12 years he's been pretty
good i think he goes right across the
tory party i think most of the
governments are full of slaves to be
honest there needs to be a change from
the very top all the way down
and if there were to be a by-election
tamworth voters will get a chance to
give their verdict on mr johnson and his
government john craig sky news